now the latest on the war in Ukraine
authorities say that days of heavy
shelling by Russian forces have killed
at least 32 people in the southern
region of Herson long lines of traffic
have built up a civilians leave the area
in search of safety Ukrainian forces
liberated her son just two weeks ago
Moscow has since kept up a Relentless
barrage of primarily targeting Power and
Water Supplies
and I'm joined Now by Dr Marina Miron
she's a research fellow in the center
for military ethics at King's College in
London good to have you with us perhaps
we could start first of all with your
assessment what impact our Russian
attacks on Ukraine's critical
infrastructure having in terms of
Ukraine's military strategy
of course obviously the of there are two
strands to this impact that Russia is
seeking to generate with those attacks
on critical infrastructure on the one
hand it creates political pressure on
the landscape because people are left in
Winter and cold without power without
water there is no Heating and so there
might be an internal pressure upon the
government despite the fact that um
Elena zelenski said that people are
ready to wait for two or three years
without electricity that they will not
give in however the situation is getting
worse and the second perhaps the most
important component is a military
component because in Winter the troops
will have to be supplied and now in
order to provide heating for the
population
Ukraine will have to rely on power
generators which use fuel and as their
main component so that will create
shortages of fuel also slow down food
supplies and food production and so on
so it will create a very
um heavy logistical strain and it will
be difficult to sustain the troops right
and on the other hand we know from
Britain's military intelligence that has
suggested that Russia is likely firing
aging cruise missiles stripped of
nuclear warheads at Ukrainian targets
what does that tell us about the state
of the Russian offensive
it tells her that Russia is obviously
slowly running out of its stocks
um for instance the likes of iskandar
and caliber missiles are getting very
low and it's very difficult for Russia
under sanctions to replenish those
stocks and it will all have also have to
think if there is a bigger escalation
with NATO it will still need those
missiles so right now it seems that
Russia is switching to cheaper missiles
it's using air defense missiles from its
s-300 systems which are not that precise
and it has no shortage of those and
um it also has a deal with Iran to
replenish missiles it's using drones to
supplement missiles it's also going to
import Fateh 110 and zolfagar missiles
from Iran as well as artillery shells
from North Korea so it is preparing for
a long War all right sir
from the center of military ethics at
King's College in London thank you so
very much for your assessments
thank you